[Musique]
50 ans pour le Festival International de
la BD d'Angoulême et 175 ans pour la BD
à la Réunion Béatrice sigismo
vice-président du département de La
Réunion et Xavier Bonnefont maire
d'Angoulême inaugure une exposition
exceptionnelle qui retrace la riche
histoire de Lille avec le lieu Vimy mars
La Réunion est une terre de BD il y a eu
un travail énorme ces dernières années
au département de La Réunion pour
accompagner non seulement la
valorisation de l'histoire patrimoniale
de la BD réunionnaise mais aussi la
création contemporaine on est fier de ce
qu'on est de ce qu'on est devenu et de
ce qu'on peut encore transmettre aux
générations futures et les documents
sont nombreux dans cette exposition pour
jouer le jeu de la transmission la
première planche remonte à 1848
l'itinéraire de Sarda gariga imaginé par
l'auteur pot et mon visible pour la
première fois dans l'Hexagone
le département a emmené ses planches
pour que le public puisse voir ce
document exceptionnel qui est peut-être
la plus ancienne BD imprimée en France
finalement on est quand même donc encore
une fois dans une œuvre qui permet de
regarder l'histoire avec un grand H et
en même temps avec le pouvoir des images
mais aussi le pouvoir de la langue
puisqu'il utilise la langue créole et
nous les pas plus mais pas moins donc
dès 1848 n'est na la langue créole aussi
que les dans une bande dessinée célébrer
ses 175 ans d'histoire de la bdpi et
tourner les pages jusqu'à celle
d'aujourd'hui pour l'événement 42 Bdx
ont fait le déplacement pour faire
découvrir leur art à un public très
attentif
le personnage que j'ai dessiné on est
cinq auteurs et autrices avoir dessiné
et moi je vois là tu as cette histoire
qui raconte l'histoire des Célimène et
Célimène c'est une voilà
et c'est l'hymen c'est une chanteuse en
fait c'est elle avait des chansons qui
étaient qui chahutaient un petit peu les
notables les gens voilà les
mères voilà donc elle c'était un peu une
on peut dire que c'est l'ancêtre elle
avait oui un côté un peu rapeuse on
apporte plusieurs voix qui viennent de
l'île et qui disent voilà on fait ça
aussi c'est pas que des plages voilà des
cocotiers c'est beaucoup beaucoup de
choses notamment et on fait partie de la
culture française
vous allez faire sur par exemple 5
il y a peut-être une suite avec
Pierre-Henri Yao et puis directeur de la
BDR et puis Christophe calciori qui est
aussi auteur en tant que co-commissaire
de l'exposition on a il y avait ça aussi
en plus évidemment il y a Angoulême il y
a le festival mais il y a la Réunion
dans cet endroit là et c'est et c'est
une petite fierté quoi c'est un petit
truc au coeur qui fait que Ben nous les
là quoi donc c'est voilà moi ça me ça me
fait vraiment quelque chose ça me fait
c'est très rare ce genre d'occasions et
là c'est une très belle occasion
une occasion rare provoquée par
l'association cyclone BD qui promet aux
Réunionnais de prochaines aventures pour
fêter ensemble ce 175e anniversaire
l'exposition sera visible pendant le
festival cyclone BD on va essayer de la
mettre encore plus en lumière et elle
sera accompagnée d'un catalogue
dédié à l'exposition les Réunionnais
pourront voir
toutes les œuvres exposées ici et
pouvoir se rendre compte des 175 années
de bande dessinée à la Réunion
[Musique]